rated T for being a little naughty hey
you still playing battleblock theater on
xbox and enjoying every moment release
oh god shut up cuz I've got two words
that will change your life forever Steam
version that's right get ready to
experience the game that won every award
for everything ever like you've never
seen it before big version
grab a friend and Hammer - the most
heartwarming / horrible story or lever
experience stay in stunt-double P&P
graphics with high resolution super
texture technology that modern human
eyeballs can't even spell then hop
online and make lots of new friends
enemies and frenemy stay and think you
can handle frame rates above the 21,000
per milliseconds that is and look a
multitude of game types is sure to keep
things interesting especially with these
state-of-the-art ragdoll physics then
part on explosion future system build
your own levels to dazzle and annoy your
friends by using our advanced
manipulation engine allowing you to
control what you see on screen the power
is in your hands oh and there's lots of
stuff to collect and write about - and
your pants will collect human feces when
you see this mind blowing a realistic
air see me
look at it so buckle said pants and get
ready to rock you miss rip support above
the five simultaneous oculus bending
video cord mega graphic throttling with
ram processors sound effects when
characters do stop the future is now I
hope you're down cuz things are about to
get awfully steamy in here
that was weird sorry I should have said
let's see let's just say the behemoth is
about to release some steam oh man that
was way better god